are you global citizens I'm Justin your
real-life English fluency coach and
today is learning this with TV lesson
I'm going to teach you 13 expressions
from hilarious scene from the popular
American TV show How I Met Your Mother
in this scene Marshall and Lily
discovered the doppelganger with a
little bit like of the friend Barney to
give you a real-life example with
doppelganger here is Leonardo DiCaprio
and here's his doppelganger this will be
a three-step lesson step one I'm going
to show you the first part of the scene
with English subtitles
then in step two I'm going to teach you
some things take it directly from this
power lesson which you can download for
free on the link above and of
information box below and finally in
step three you're going to watch it
again without subtitles with a
completely new perspective let's do this
oh yeah
kids up to this point in the story we
had found doppelgangers eerie but
awesome look-alikes for four of the five
members of our little group there was
lesbian Robert
mustache Marshall stripper Lily and
Mexican wrestler me yes mine was the
coolest and so we were all eager to find
the fifth doppelganger Barneys turned
out it was more important to some of us
than others
we agreed there's no sense in having a
baby until we've seen all five
doppelgangers right of course stands to
reason okay so we finally see Barney's
doppelganger that's the universe telling
us it's go time and that's what we'll
start trying deal deal and then one day
a few weeks later baby are you serious
about the whole fifth doppelganger thing
I mean having a baby is a playful thing
to leave up to the universe yeah I know
it's crazy it's just so much easier to
let the universe decide why do you ask
hmm universe oh my god
how does step one go 1% if you
understand if you understood the general
idea awesome just so you know that scene
was packed with advanced vocabulary
which we're going to take a closer look
at right now for optimal learning pause
this video right now and download this
two-page power lesson for free by
joining the real life image power
learning club on the link above or in
the information box below oh yeah let's
move on to step two and up to this point
in the story kids up to this point in
the story the narrator of How I Met Your
Mother is the older version of Ted one
of the main characters in the year 2030
the series is a story of how Ted met
their mother on doppelgangers eerie but
awesome look-alikes doppelganger eerie
but awesome look-alikes eerie is to
cause an exploitable feeling of
weirdness or even fear here's a very
eerie scene with a dog on a very strange
Street look-alike is someone who looks
like or resembles another person in this
case Barney here's a real-life
doppelganger of Barney
it seems he's a basketball player
stripper Lily
and Mexican wrestler me stripper Lily
and Mexican wrestler me stripper is a
person who removes their clothes and a
sexually exciting away here's a picture
of stripper Lily she looks just like
Lily Mexican wrestler meet Ted here's a
picture of a wrestler and here's a
picture of Ted the narrator and so we
were all eager to find the fifth
doppelganger Barney's and so we were all
eager to find the fifth doppelganger
Barney's eager is to be enthusiastic
about doing something here's a picture
of a student who's very eager to answer
the teachers question turned out it was
more important to some of us than others
turned out it was more important to some
of us than others
it's turn out is to happen in a
particular way or to have a result we
agree there's no sense in having a baby
until we've seen all five doppelgangers
right of course
stands to reason of course stands to
reason stands to reason means it's
obvious based on the facts not very
common that's the universe telling us
it's go time and that's what we'll start
trying deal deal that's the universe
telling us it's go time and that's when
we'll start trying deal deal go time is
the plan start time for something
specific start trying to have a baby
it's a deal it's to arrive at an
agreement or contract a baby is a pretty
big thing to leave up to the universe
having a baby is a pretty big thing to
leave up to the universe to leave up to
is to seed or release control or power
for a decision why do you ask
universe oh my god why do you ask
boom universe boom is a sound used to
affirm something exciting and or
unexpected universe is a verb that
Marshall invented to give action to the
noun universe this is not a real word
English is a fun language that can be
used to make verbs from nouns
to more examples of verbing a noun
include to Google for example I don't
believe you let me Google that or friend
hey can you friend me on Facebook now
before we do the final step 3 of this
lesson which is to watch this season
once again without subtitles I just want
to thank you for watching for learning
with us remember here we let English our
mission is for you not just to learn
English to live it to access the power
lesson for this entire scene including
the conclusion which is not included in
this video we encourage you to join the
power learning club by clicking on the
link for free above now let's take what
we've learned and to limit the final
step free by watching the scene one more
time without subtitles oh yeah kids up
to this point in the story we had found
doppelgangers eerie but awesome
look-alikes for four of the five members
of our little group there was lesbian
Robert
mustache Marshall stripper Lily and
Mexican wrestler me yes mine was the
coolest
and so we were all eager to find the
fifth doppelganger Barneys turned out it
was more important to some of us than
others
we agreed there's no sense in having a
baby until we've seen all five
doppelgangers right of course stands to
reason okay so we finally see Barney's
doppelganger that's the universe telling
us it's go time and that's what we'll
start trying deal deal and then one day
a few weeks later baby are you serious
about the whole fifth doppelganger thing
I mean having a baby is a playful thing
to leave up to the universe yeah I know
it's crazy it's just so much easier to
let the universe decide why do you ask
hmm you reversed oh my god wait wait
hold on that could easily be Barney
pulling some scam to meet chicks one
step ahead of you go over Barney Barney
hey it's Marshall so you are at work
you're not I don't know driving a cab
wearing a wig yes I'm at work that's the
sound of my stapler that's the sound of
my three-hole punch and this is the
sound of me filing my corporate
guidelines on sexual harassment what is
I gotta go Big Chief
Barney's at work
yep that was the fifth doppelganger
Marshall Eriksen
put a baby in my belly
the world